you know yesterday we played uh these
two videos from nba players uh bradley
deal of the washington wizards and
jonathan isaac of the orlando magic
talking about vaccines and the and the
video by jonathan isaac was particularly
interesting i thought because he's very
common measured he talks about being
young and physically fit and having
coveted natural antibodies he talks
about personal choice he really does it
in a sort of evolved interesting way we
showed you an extended clip of it
yesterday but i want to just show you
about a 30 second clip of it right now
what is it about the vaccine that that
makes you
uh
hesitant to to to get it uh i i would
start with um i've had covet um in the
past and so our understanding of
antibodies
of natural immunity has uh changed a
great deal from the onset of the
pandemic and is still evolving
um
i understand that the vaccine would um
help if you catch covid and uh you'll be
able to have less symptoms um from
contracting it but with me having covert
in the past and having antibodies um
with my current um age group and a
fitness physical fitness level um it's
not necessarily a fear of mine okay so
if you want to watch the more extended
version of that we played it yesterday
the reason i'm playing it again today is
because obviously what you're seeing
there is a thoughtful interesting
individual who is
non-judgmental trying to
talk about this stuff in a calm way well
now we've got and i hate to show you a
clip from don lemon's show
former nba superstar and uh pilot of uh
co-pilot of the plane and airplane
kareem abdul-jabbar talking about
unvaccinated nba players and i want you
to listen to the difference in tone and
tenor of what he's saying
i think they should be disciplined uh i
don't think that they are
behaving like good teammates or good
citizens um
this is a war that we're involved in and
masks and uh vaccines
they are the weapons that we use to to
fight this war
and uh when you're not gonna
be cooperative with that uh
you're working against the effort to
make everybody safe and uh you know we
can't have that that
that doesn't work for everybody you know
i'm actually really sad to say this you
know i'm an old-school nba fan but
kareem abdul-jabbar is just a ridiculous
human being at this point
what what jonathan isaac said there was
true and again watch the watch the more
extended version of it from yesterday's
show if you want
and it was thoughtful what karim is
saying is do what we want it doesn't
matter if you have immunity already it
doesn't matter if you're young and
healthy and eat right and any of that
stuff do what we want because we want
you to do it and if you don't do it
you're not a good person now i would
like to know and maybe kareem or don
lemon could do a little research on this
how many nba players have transmitted
kovid to other nba players during the
games where they're often sweating on
each other and spitting on each other
and you know you can uh go to block a
shot and your nails could get on
somebody and they start bleeding was
there a massive outbreak by nba players
young person to young person the peak of
physical performance that's what the
shape that these guys are in did that
ever happen but kareem doesn't care
about that because we're watching this
sort of massive
brain
experiment happening to everybody where
everyone seemingly that is mainstream at
this point just wants to go along with
what they are told so it does not matter
the same people who will tell you that
they believe in science which is why
kareem i suppose believes in the vaccine
and the masks and all that he believes
in science well why isn't he then
talking about young healthy people and
people who have had covet and natural
immune and everything else but he wants
you to be a good person and speaking of
good people you're not going to believe
this we found video of kareem
abdul-jabbar saying the complete reverse
when it had to do with people protesting
about racial justice
i'm really pleased to see
the diversity of all the people that
that have taken to the streets and have
not gone home
that to me is extraordinary i never
thought i'd live to see that and i'm
glad to see that a very diverse
cross-section of america understands
that you know systemic racism
it's a cancer and
we can't live with it and we have to
figure out ways to eliminate it
you get what we just did there kareem
abdul-jabbar was very excited when all
sorts of people some wearing masks some
weren't were protesting against systemic
racism he liked that diverse
cross-section of people getting out
there and about to protest racism tear
down america down with the patriarchy
but now
now that we're not really talking about
systemic racism anymore right we've got
biden in charge you know it's not trump
anymore so we're not a racist country
anymore i suppose something like that um
so the you know we're not rioting in
that regard anymore that would be too
much to handle biden solved racism i
suppose uh but now he's lecturing nba
players who are young thoughtful in this
case the two guys of the videos that i
played yesterday two young uh black men
who i believe are entitled to their
opinion um he thinks they're bad people
so when it when it was for racial
justice which he's for then get out
there folks spread the disease be a good
human diversity and when it ain't you're
a bad person
kareem you're a bad person sorry i don't
know how else to look at it if if you
think things only spread if you think
viruses only spread uh when it fits your
political narrative the problem is on
you there's a virus in your head uh
that's far worse than the cobot virus